today on the anime zone or a view of
steins gate an anime tackling the
complex and mind-bending issue of time
travel but more importantly it answers
the age-old question that has been
plaguing scientists for centuries now
what does happen if you text the phone
that's attached to a microwave
[ __ ]
it's a rare occurrence that I delve into
the world of anime watches following
anime that's currently airing because
for one the chances of finding a good
anime are to the dozens of anime coming
out every season is approximately the
same chances betting all your money on
the number of a roulette ball the size
of the London Eye and 40 if you do have
an amazing finds then you're suddenly
stuck with a piddly twenty minutes of
entertainment every week or every other
waking hours spent willing your thumbs
like an idiot counting on a seconds to
the time when you'll get your next
weekly twenty minutes anime boner so the
majority of the time I wait until an
anime is finished airing or has been
licensed and dubbed the your time when I
do pop my head up and watch an anime
fresh off the market is when the anime
community explodes from collectively
tossing off to the same show
so to challenge the hype surrounding the
series I'm reviewing Stein skate Stein
skaters anelia 2011 anime based on a
vision of of the same name and follows
the adventures of self-proclaimed mad
scientist okabe rintarou and his group
of friends as they somehow build a time
machine that's able to send text
messages to the Past as a team start
abusing the machine like a crack addict
who's been given free drugs a garbage
scene realizes the repercussions of
screwing around with time which throws
him into a world full of conspiracies
murders and make a phase where he must
use his knowledge of time travel to fix
the chaos he's caused from a very dark
feature that no one could have predicted
now with my opinion of the current anime
climates being that his mostly slice of
slide or Maui or both or crap thighs
gate was a breath of fresh air was Mars
above any other recent series I've seen
in terms of plot the story had more
twists and turns I've seen in any show
since code geass 12 Lee's plot twists
mostly coming from our lack of
understanding when it comes to time
travel allowing the author to
effectively theorize his own science in
the understanding of the quantum
mechanics inherent behind the
paradoxical results of jumping through
time aka
he can make [ __ ] up or as the doctor
would say people assume that time is a
strict progression of cause to effect
but actually from a nonlinear
non-subjective viewpoint it's more like
a big ball of wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey
stuff science but if you can get past
then just accept the illogical science
for what it is then you're in for a
treat because this show is the best I've
seen the time-travel concept done in
anime while also being surprisingly fun
at times most the fun comes from our
main character okabe rintarou or as he
likes to be known oh sure MA and yes the
name does need to be shouted out like
you're a [ __ ] he is a scientist who
somehow [ __ ] around with a microwave
so much they actually caused a rip in
the space-time continuum
he calls himself a mad scientist cuz
apparently all you need to need to be
classified as mad scientist is where
white lab coats shout
everything out in the loudest of marches
man you can possibly think of and laugh
like a [ __ ] but don't take my word for
I'm sure he can give a better
introduction of himself than I ever
could
AMS scientist it's so cool
instead of effect songs to be honest
he's the only character that really
matters because he's the only one that
he changes during the course of the show
thanks to the time-travel pull up
developments and because of this the
rest of the characters can be pretty
much summed up in one sentence there's
Chris who the redhead teenage genius
who's definitely not in the Thunderer
whatever my Yuri the cuter who starts of
every sentence like a broken tape
recorder the fat otaku is basically Todd
from scrubs charting out sexual
innuendos every turn a person whose
deadly obsessed with fuck-buddies of
Facebook or of the [ __ ] FB stands for
and I go who says nyan alot no seriously
her name is Faris nyan yawn she ends
every sentence with the word nyan and
she works in a place called made Queen
yangyang as why she's a [ __ ]
unsurprisingly she was bloody annoying
oh and there's also a girl who works on
the TV so in a very cute and innocent
girl who is uh you know what never mind
it's a trap
anyway as I mentioned earlier the
biggest drinks of this show is the plot
while time travel was nothing new in the
sci-fi genre the show does its best to
give its own original take on everything
providing a plot that keeps you engaged
surprise and even emotionally involved
at some points though having said
although the series can be very
light-hearted and funny at the same time
in fact the first half this series feels
more like a slice-of-life comedy with a
time-travel twist to it which isn't
necessarily a bad thing since just
watching the banter between the various
cast members can be quite fun and
entertaining but the show really shines
in the second half when it quickly
shifts into a more serious tone when it
becomes apparent for holy Schumer
while the consequences for messing with
time are as far as the animation goes
it's nothing spectacular most of the
time but smooths out in the moments when
he really needs you for greater fate and
as for the music it always sets the mood
perfectly even when I think back nothing
really stands out another big thing I
have to give a show credit for is how
well researched it is okay a show about
time travel will inevitably have some
made-up [ __ ] in it but it tries his
best to present a very original way of
time travel while also having references
through events actually happened in the
real world such as that whole CERN black
hole Fiasco and John Titor but despite
the majority of the series keeping me on
the edge of my seat there were some
things are bugged me about the show
firstly the
started the series which so incredibly
slow since one I was very much
interested in the whole time-travel
concept and the possible effects were
messing with it the characters himself
seem to be more interested in
researching the newest and most
cutting-edge methods of [ __ ] around
literally all I remember from these
episodes were a banana a microwave a
banana and angry redhead a green banana
a perverted fat mad more bananas a mad
scientist bus got [ __ ] and
absolutely [ __ ] all happening and
bananas and this sound the anime only
really starts get interesting when they
complete the first time machine about 6
episodes in and even then the real meat
of the story comes after episode 12
so there's take some time for the story
property gets going secondly during the
latter third of the series this made
painfully obvious that this was based on
a visual novel just from the fact there
are suddenly a couple of episodes where
all six girls five and a half were
basically queuing up to have their own
one-on-one private time with the main
character and for a brief period the
show went from this heart-pounding
edge-of-your-seat time-travel thriller
to the [ __ ] dating show starring
wholly sure mom's dead event needless to
say it felt tacked on and very out of
place with all the events that were
happening around them which may be
wonder if this was just based on a
simple Japanese a visual novel or am a
simple Japanese visual novel in tag
games and a fact is the characters were
the weakest part of steins gate since I
already really like oh sure MA and Cody
soo frankly the chemistry between these
two just overshadowed any other
character interaction in the series and
most of the characters themselves were
actually quite the stereotypical anime
archetypes excluding the main character
oh and I know that now some of you are
going to call me a heartless bastard for
not caring about my URI and all I have
to say to you is overall steins gate
wasn't the absolute greatest anime in
the world but in comparison to the
recent run of animes coming out in the
past few years it's definitely up there
is one of the best it portrays a very
original method of time-travel one has a
very well-written plot with the most
twists and turns i've seen in years so
it's just unfortunate that is that done
by very slow start and the lack of an
original and developed cast does it live
up to the hype as the best new anime FR
no I still enjoyed the heck of em hell
I'd rather the anime community behind
our flawed series with a great plot a
rather
then I pretend to show with a whiny
Yozgat and over-aged show about an
annoying us get or even worse
[ __ ] tea
imagine
yeah
fool